hey everybody and welcome to a red
Rockin wild ride with Stevo this is the
last thing we did before coming out to
Australia where I am now with the bus
that is actually working this is just so
exciting and this Australia tour is off
the charts
and this week's episode is Sammy Hagar
it is unbelievable how rich and frankly
scandalous this guy's history is with
Van Halen with uh what do you say he got
kicked out of every band he was ever in
and man the amount of money this guy has
made is shocking like literally
unbelievable plus he couldn't be nicer
we had such a good time with Sammy Hagar
and so will you right now so let's get
into it
we got this great liquid death oh yeah I
know this stuff
thank you
but yeah [__] man and then we became
friends just like he's one of my my dear
friends I love the guy but when I did
the show I didn't know him that well yet
and we and he I was intimidated by him
he was me too man yeah like I was I was
he's thick man he's like he's tight his
[__] is tight that's what he was talking
about I was kind of uh
stumbling over myself because between
being such a huge fan and like him being
so mysterious yeah he's like Mystique
brother man he's more than any guy in
the business when he agreed to do my
show I was tripping I'm going wow I got
[__] Maynard doing my show there and
I got the weirdest love from that it was
from weird people that you were saying
yeah you know okay what what color are
we going with for you we can make this
oh you got to go with the Red Rocker I'm
sorry
what kind of sure
cheers first of all yeah for sure man
cheers to you
and um
okay so here we go we're gonna we're
gonna just start it like this
ladies and gentlemen Sammy Hagar
yeah
it really really if I live up to that
that profanity okay so this is my
co-host Scott Randolph how you doing
Scott good how you doing and now for the
first time ever
we have
both
Vinnie and Paul this is crazy oh Vinnie
and Paul I like that there's there's so
far been two eras of the Wild Ride
podcast there was the Paul Briskey era
and then we said Paul left and was
replaced by Vinnie
it's cool I like that Vinnie Paul was
your dear friend Vinnie Paul is it was
it was the coolest guy who is he the
drummer in uh uh uh Pantera Pantera
we had a little bit of a Van Halen
effect over here
and it's the triumphant return of Paul
Briskey yes
yeah the gorgeous Paul brisket so I'm
David Lee Roth in this situation
hey man we're not out to get you Sammy
no wait you wouldn't be I wouldn't be
here if I thought you were yeah
um now Where Do We Begin man what what a
fascinating I mean I knew you were
fascinating but as I did some research
preparing for this I just Blown Away by
how rich and and how I juicy the history
is you know oh that's what I thought you
said oh Richard
I'm not denying it
it's the last thing people want to hear
about is how rich is yeah but no the you
know I I really at my age I've done it
so much stuff because I'm old and it's
like and I've become I've stayed healthy
and I've been able to sing I can still
sing as good as I ever sang and I'm
still sing the same songs they're tuned
down a little bit no problem though I've
seen this you know I don't have to cheat
but long story short when you've been
around a long time if you really care
and like to do [__] then you will have
done a lot of [__] and Longevity is
where it's at man you know longevity
you know these guys that died young man
you made you know one album two albums
that just feel terrible about that right
how old are you 75. unbelievable I know
my dad said it is that's great my dad
just turned 80. and I really think that
he has uh just dealt Father Time a [__]
slap to the face I mean like he's so
healthy but but I think that my dad
doesn't have anything on you I think I'm
not 80 yet but you know everybody says
well when you turn 70 you talk to Willie
Nelson these guys are very few guys
older than me in this still in the
business and I would ask him you know
you know and say [__] man you know how
you doing Willie you're 70 you're
[__] out there doing it he's going
yeah you know when turned 70 is a little
tougher you know and all this [__] and
I'm I'm thinking yeah I turned 70 wasn't
didn't make any difference to me so I'm
looking at 80 now I'm thinking well
maybe that's the one where I'm gonna go
damn you know right so what do you do to
stay so healthy Cabo Wabo no I drink I
do every [__] thing
I've never had
that there you go we're still recording
recording recording everything's still
going all right I'm pushing on for the
people just listening our lights went
out oh so this is live we're uh no no no
oh you scared me there it's not it's not
live but uh there are people who have
just the audio and then some people have
both the video and audio do we need to
turn oh there we go
nothing shut off right no no
everything's still recording but they're
like Master on wasn't working but I just
did individually all the lights out I
don't know so more information so
basically it was what I was about to say
is that you know I've never I don't know
why I'm not an addiction kind of guy I
don't get addicted to [__] I don't I'm
not addicted to [__] golf I'm
addicted to sex and food and and a good
time in the beach you know and right but
not not drugs and stuff you know it's
like I I take every I mean I've taken
I've taken anything and everything I've
[__] you know I drink every night you
know I don't drink in the daytime I
don't wake up with the shakes and [__]
you know I don't know Mom some of my
friends can't do that so right so I
don't know I don't know if that's what's
keeping me young but I mean I'd at least
never had to go get fixed right right
you know and I you know walk on the
beach every day I used to be a running
fanatic a bicycling fanatic uh that was
a little fanatical you ever surf no no
okay I'm a whole dad I love the beach
I'm a complete Beach Nut but I don't get
up on that board I get at my age now if
I got sitting on you know the wave would
be gone by the time I got up on that
[__] floor right my knees are kind of
shot that's the only thing I [__] up
jumping around on stage you know okay do
you uh did you ever were you friends
with Val Kilmer no because because like
uh you know I watch footage of you look
at you and there's just this little
resemblance really yeah
no I was watching um
uh the I Can't Drive 55 music video and
when you grab the cop and you get in his
face I was like who's he remind me of
there and it was Oh What a trip that's
in 1984 that was before if I was right
was rocking the uh the video stuff right
I mean the movie stuff right I mean
right
um that I mean it's about when uh when
Val came on the scene I think well maybe
he was copying me you know what I'm
saying hey Val right
now going back to you know that that
early your first band that wasn't a
cover band was Mantra yeah that's right
72 73. and you got kicked out of
Montrose I get kicked out of every
[__] band I mean that's why I'm I I
become a solo artist it's so funny
um I I you know I guess my free spirit
type attitude you know and and
um taking things seriously but not you
know to a to degree of of some other
people that these band leader guys you
know that they just want to control you
but they don't really
it's like an ego trip it's not real like
when I want to control somebody like
okay I don't want you getting all [__]
up before the show we got work to do you
know I mean that's the kind of control I
use other than that do whatever [__] you
want you know but uh yeah Ronnie yeah I
just rubbed him wrong I guess and he
fired me yeah it's really weird and um
see he fired himself eventually you know
right
so you get kicked out of Montrose and
that's when you first become a solo
artist yeah even though it was never
your intention to be a solo artist no
not at that time I was trying to put a
band together you know that was like and
as a solo artist you just blew away
mondra what are the guys from Montrose
go on to do after he left well the
drummer Denny karmasi he went on to
playing on all the White Snake big
records he became like a studio guy and
then then he joined heart the second
generation at heart with all those top
40 hits when the girls were all
glamorous and [__] uh the video hits so
he was in that band for a long time so
he did good bill Church the bass player
didn't do much he came with me
um and uh Ronnie he just kept firing
people kept changing becoming
instrumental artists get a new singer I
had to do this or that he was a hard guy
to get along with I mean he shot himself
in the head God bless him you know what
I'm saying that's all you got to say
about it guys eventually that does that
so he was miserable and we but he'd
never let you get close to him he was he
was one of them guys uh as soon as he
got close to him he'd get all [__]
weird you know if you had a conversation
you know well you talk about anything
deep yeah when you in those days we had
a room together you know so Ronnie and I
would ruin a bass playing a drummer and
and running you know we sit up late at
night you know maybe have a couple
drinks and start talking Soulful [__]
man then I'll send the next day he'd be
like all [__] weird and [__] it's
like Whoa man you know I didn't tell you
[__] man you know I mean he was like
really weird like the [__] you didn't
tell me nothing you know did your dad
beat you or something you know what I
mean wouldn't you uh you'd run with
Ronnie but then you'd switch Yeah
but we always ended up
Ronnie and I always ended up because
nobody wanted his room at the bass
player Bill church he was an [__]
so it was like musical chairs to avoid
the bass player yeah he he was bitter he
was always complaining everything was oh
[__] this [__] that you know and I was
the happiest guy in the world broke on
my ass you know but man you know I was
getting laid every night and I was
jumping on stage every night and you
know my phone was shut off at home but
it's all right you know I didn't I'd
rather be on the road I was loving it
that's great so so you're just start
killing it with your with your solo band
no no I'm I was a I'm a journeyman man I
I never had that overnight success thing
and my work ethic I think is what broke
me because um
you know I wanted it bad so I was I was
in shape I was running every day I said
I get on stage I got singly loud and run
faster and jump higher and [__] play
fast and all you [__] that was
my him out you know I wanted to be you
know the baddest [__] guy in rock you
know so so I I worked I went out and I
played seven nights a week I'd open for
anybody anytime he played so I get
thrown off tours just like getting
kicked out of bands all the time I've
you know open for people and they'd say
get this guy out of here man I'm not
gonna have me going out there doing all
that before we go on it can't be too
much of a journeyman though if you've
got Platinum selling albums in five
consecutive decades right yeah but it
took a while my first platinum album
first gold album didn't come until about
two
and I started in 73 so you know I ran a
10-year run there you're not selling
records I was selling tickets started
the first one
the first one that went gold was
actually the red album Sammy Hagar um
but that was from 1977 but it didn't go
gold until 1982 and then 82 standing
Hampton was with uh my first hit I'll
fall in love again stuff that that I got
signed again for the records and that
sold it went gold quick and I had a hit
record and they pushed me you know they
were into it the other record company I
was on Capital they just said ah he's
going to go out and work and sell record
we have to put any money in behind him
you know I mean so they never put money
behind the records so my first goal down
was sanding Hampton and then it went
platinum three lock box platinum gold
you know boa 50. I can't drive 55. then
I you know I broke as a as a an artist
and start selling shitload of records
and
getting uh my dream come true you know
right how many is gold 500 000 500 000
yeah you can't sell 500 000 records
today
people don't buy the records anymore
right and then what's a million is
Platinum Platinum double Platinum is 10
million two two of them ten is a diamond
diamond yeah I don't have a diamond
record I've got plenty of seven and
eight millions of Van Halen and yeah
yeah but no we uh no tins those tins are
those are for the pop guys that have
that big number one single and have
three number one single leg Yeah I think
Journey's got a a diamond record for
sure their greatest hits records
probably okay bands like that wow so
yeah so so you break and you know you're
selling a ton of records and and then
all of a sudden you find out David Lee
Roth left Van Halen and you said to your
wife you were married at that time yeah
okay first wife this is my second one
you said you said your wife they're
going to call me
well it was weird because because I was
sitting at dinner and I was working with
Ted templeman I had done the VOA I Can't
Drive 55 record Ted had produced all the
Van Halen records and the Roth solo
stuff so Ted and I were friends he'd
produce Montrose Ted templeman so we had
this long relationship so he'd call me
up so I was saying hey I just came home
from a tour and stuff and I was going
well I'm not gonna I'm not gonna uh
you know make a record right away and
kids go no we should get back in the
studio I want to see what your good
start writing you know he was pushing me
so he'd call me and and uh so I'm at
dinner and he calls him and I say he's
saying uh wow you can believe this you
know Roth quit Van Halen I said what
really wow
yeah well we don't know we don't know
look they said that I quit too right
I got fired
so um so did him no so I turned to my
wife and as soon as I hung up I said wow
they you know go back to eating yeah
Dave you know quit the band and said
well then I just went [__] they're going
to call me my my brain I'm a real good
calculator you know I I calculate things
really fast put things together it's
just it's a gift and uh and I just went
John Ronnie James do uh Ozzy Osbourne
Sammy Hagar they're gonna call me you
know it was kind of pretty obvious it
you know it's like I don't know I I was
already
the thought of somebody replacing
Dave was going to be very strange but I
knew musically in my head Ted templeman
knew too you know that that was like no
you you and Eddie get together it's
going to be [__] the [__] man man it
was and and
um it
in the final analysis did it turn out
that they had considered other people
yeah later on when after I got thrown
out of the band then I started hearing
all these [__] rumors that they were
going to be Patty Smythe and that's
because Eddie was out of a relationship
with him he's like hey we joined my band
yeah
uh and they're I don't know I guess a
couple other people stood up and said oh
Daryl Hall said Yeah Eddie was really
you know at that time he he was pretty
wasted a lot of times and we all were
you know but but you know he Eddie we
know now that you know any had a lot of
drugs and drinking problems so he would
get [__] up and tell people hey man
I'm a bartender you know so yeah people
came out of the woodwork but the truth
of the matter is is that originally they
Ted templeman when they started when he
signed him he said you should get Sammy
Hagar because I Gotta Throw it in
Montrose you know I was solo wasn't
doing very good and he said you should
get Sammy Hagar in his [__] van right
and Eddie was saying yeah you think he'd
do it and they were all thinking about
it and um you know then they made a
record and exploded so they never
thought about it again I guess but I
heard that from before his mouth from
all of them yeah man they were Temple
was pushing for you to be in the band
but that wouldn't that would have been
[__] up it was much better the way I
came in we were all grown up they I was
already selling millions they were
selling me we're selling out renas they
were selling out Arenas get together Pam
it you know yeah it became you know one
of the biggest bands in the world you
know all number one albums we had I mean
that was that's a run brother let me
tell you something I that's a [__]
run we had here for sure 10 years you
know and is it true that uh in the David
Lee Roth era from the David Lee Roth
there Van Halen sold 46 million hours
albums and in the Sammy Hagar era they
sold 46 million yeah you know it's about
it's about equal now that's funny that
you said I mean you said 46 I said no
that's what we sold but it's like the
thing we had was these number one albums
we came uh in a at a point where we got
so much more attention
the music was um you know more
commercial not not intentionally I mean
there's somebody Music Eddie was [__]
writing on keyboards you know he loved
to play keyboards and I'd hear this [__]
I go [__] you know that's awesome you
know when it's love and and uh Love
Walks In and and stuff like that and so
Eddie go you like that I'm going yeah
because I guess Rob didn't like
keyboards so uh so we you know really
kind of spread out and started selling
more records instantly the reason the
their old catalog though they had that
[__] jump that was the biggest song
Van Halen ever had you know David
they're out didn't like keyboards huh
exactly there you go but when when
people you know meet me oh you're you
know the singer in Van Halen oh you know
somebody don't know [__] you know this
is the first thing they think I sing
[__] jump I'm going damn that thing
haunts me you know what I mean because
that was a big big record so that really
allowed them that song gets AirPlay
still today and still allows their old
catalog to sell to to a younger
generation to where mine is still
selling too but a younger generation
will come along next on on mine because
it was two different decades you know
right and that's the way the music
business is comes back around you could
talk to Tom Tom and I were talking about
that last night how the crew went down
into the toilet a generation when the
grunge came out you know the crew kind
of went to pieces and Van Halen took a
little dip and you know and then all of
a sudden now the crew is bigger than
they ever been because it's a second
time around you know they have those
those girls girls girls those hits you
know and uh and a younger generation
picks up on them so that's what's
happening right now at the van Hagar
catalog we're having this big Resurgence
and they re-mastered all the whole
catalog and they're doing all these
things I don't care about all that
because for me I'm not even in the music
business it's my been my hobby from day
one and yeah but now it's like I don't
even worry about it I love it I just go
play when I want to play you know it's
it's not like a business to me right
right but Warners is all behind the van
hang count as they see the trend you
know they're going oh people are the
younger Generations streaming and all
these things so it's like Matthew
McConaughey in that movie we get older
they just stay the same age because new
people are discovering things all the
time and one thing people are
discovering these days is liquid death
it is a canned water and iced tea
company that's saving the world because
they're infinitely recyclable
aluminum cans are so much better for the
environment than plastic plus their new
liquid death iced tea is so much
healthier than those other Iced Teas out
there and if you order liquid death iced
tea on Amazon you get free shipping plus
from the local retailers some of them
around you now if you're a listener of
the Wild Ride podcast you get an extra
special deal because you get 20 off your
first apparel purchase if you go to
liquiddeath.com
Stevo that's liquiddeath.com
Stevo and hurry up and jump on that deal
now let's get back to it
you think about he's been in Eddie
Shadow his whole life and uh
but he had to be the boss because he's
older brother so he was always the boss
so they had a Trippy relationship you
know they'd get into it they'll be
throwing blows I wrote about all the
stuff in my book and Mike and I we go
hey you guys breaking up next thing
we're [__] I'm rolling around with
Alex on the ground like hey don't come
between us man we're [__] Brothers
whoa go ahead then we'd leave and then
[__] the next day we come back to the
studio trash cans turned upside down
Windows knocked out as [__] let's go man
you know but they didn't want you to
come between them yeah that is crazy
that blood is thicker than mud it's some
true [__] man
um when when you were on tour in the
Heyday of Van Hagar were you singing
David Lee Roth catalog on stage not in
the first tour first tour we did
um You Really Got Me
and we did I Can't Drive 55 and uh no we
didn't you really got me in one way to
rock we didn't even do I can't drive
here and we just played the whole new
out the first 5150 record and then for
an encore we would play jump but I would
pull somebody out of the audience to
sing it wow that was an [__] I mean
honestly complete you know guilty as
sharks right
it's like I didn't want to sing the
songs because I thought jump was a silly
song I I didn't like the lyric and I had
a hard time sitting up there going can't
you see me standing here I got my back
against the record machine you know what
I mean you know what I mean
I had a hard time with it all right I
came from Montrose all right I'm talking
about rock candy baby sticking you know
so I just didn't like Ross lyrics
on that song but some of the stuff was
really good I mean you know Unchained
and [__] ain't talking about love and
you know even Running With The Devils
Running With the Devil yeah that's you
know that's good [__] man I'm not down
on that stuff at all and later on I
started getting a little more user
friendly but then we had more albums so
we didn't need it so okay
Eddie was the one that didn't want to
play the catalog Eddie was the one that
wanted to keep the name Van Halen
because Warner Brothers said why don't
you call a van Hagar and I'm going yeah
it's kind of an ego trip for me I wasn't
I felt a little embarrassed but um Eddie
was no man [__] Sam he's one of the
Bands fan hill now you know we're this
is Van Halen you know right and he
wasn't a real assertive guy but when he
did you know you'd say Amen you know the
man knows man the Jesus
I think uh Eddie was right on that one
keep it Van Halen [__] yeah what kind of
stuff was on a Van Halen writer for your
shows well that brown m m thing went off
the window because I dig Brown Eminem
so let's start right there yeah
you know we had a ball of tequila always
you know I was I've always been a
tequila Guy and um but I never drink
that much if I still just won that much
oh well we all had separate dress rooms
to start with so I'm just saying about
my dress room Eddie's room is probably
it changed every year uh honestly I
[__] don't remember we you know we
carried a chef so they cooked for us and
a lot of times we weren't hungry after a
show you know
[Laughter]
we'd barely make it through the shower
before the action happened man no we
partied hard man I really did we partied
hard ain't no question about it I don't
know if you've read my book I'm not
trying to push my book but but I mean
let's be clear the the thread number one
New York Times bestseller man that's a
big deal that's a really big deal I'm a
New York Times bestseller but not number
one you know when it went number one I
cried my [__] eyes out I for some
reason the timing of that book was
really right and Howard Stern read
because he's a big Van Halen yeah I read
it on on the air and it just went pow
wow it's always the first week like 37
000 copies they were so backlogged they
printed 7 500 books and they had orders
for 37 000 and
um and when my Publishers call call me I
just went wow I [__] cried it was
such now that's I've had so many dreams
that I didn't dream come true you know I
mean like well I didn't dream that you
know I'd ramp to be a rock star okay but
but you know the number one book and
having a tequila company that becomes
the number two premium tequila in the
world wonderful people you know crazy
enough to buy it for the kind of money
it was and they weren't crazy I mean now
I know the business they were smart they
were saying this guy doesn't know what
he's doing man we'll take this [__]
and you know double his sales in five
minutes Genius of you to only sell 80 of
it though well that was not genius see
everyone thinks I'm so smart I am not so
smart Stevo I was thinking oh yeah
they'll make it worldwide they'll double
if I sell the 20 for what I've got for
the 80 and it didn't work that way it
was uh what if you hung on to it though
what if you still had that 20 today
oh yeah that'd be a whole different
story see that would have been genius
but I had to sell it within seven years
see they're a public Trading Company and
you can't have Partners like that you
got to have uh you know so they've made
a special deal with me but it's not like
they [__] me just said I wasn't smart
enough to know that
when they took it over they dumped a
bunch of money into it so the profit
margin when I owned it I hadn't put no
money and I had four sales guys I didn't
know what I was doing it was just
selling like crazy you know couldn't
keep it on the shelf so I was making all
this money every year I was making like
seven eight million dollars profit in my
pocket a year for the last those last
three years as it averaged out to 6.7
million per year so that's what they
went for three years what was my average
net
and I went [__] so they offered me 10
times net which was 67 million dollars
and I'm going [__] man that's you know I
was flipping out and then I thought [__]
I love this brand I'm having a blast and
making all this money it's growing man
[__] you I don't want to sell it what
would it take blah blah blah that's how
it got jacked way up but the point is
the 20 then also they start dumping
money into it they charge 13 management
fee they had all these things yeah and
so the profit margin went down so my 10
times well they offered me I end up
paying 15 times 15 times earnings on the
years after I sold it it wasn't earning
nearly as much money ah since they
weren't talking about 10 times what you
had made off of it that's right they
were talking about what they were making
because they had 37 sales guys and right
and trucks and [__] sure yeah it
takes money to make money yeah but they
you know they came out good in the end
after they got rid of me
now trust me I did not get [__] but I
[__] myself because a lot I actually
got 97 ml million instead of a hundred
ah darn it I'll tell you that three
million I could have given to you
Stephen you killed yourself with that
money yeah you wouldn't be here today
and depending on the year
um you do give away a lot of money I do
that that's uh it's incredible you got
you got a whole I mean can we call it a
restaurant chain that it's like Paul
Newman all of the money goes to charity
yeah my my restaurant's in the in the
called the Sammy's beach bar and grills
that are built around my beach bar rum
brand
uh are in airports there's one Honolulu
uh Maui Cleveland and Las Vegas and uh
there's a couple more going to be opened
up pretty soon and I give all that money
that I make on those restaurants to that
community that local yeah because I'm a
big
I'm big on philanthropy but not given
money some [__] way off place to some
big corporation that just sticks it in
the bank account I'm Grassroots man I go
through the hospital in Maui and we find
this the children in a serious most
serious condition that their parents
have run out of
um Insurance are never had insurance and
I pay for the transportation to get them
back and forth to the hospital we pay
for their medicine things like right
straight to one family and I have to do
it through hospital because most of
these people are on uh assistance from
government assistance and if you give
them money they'll take you off and if
they buy them a car well they can't have
a car they're on you know we're not
gonna you know it's really tricky so you
go to the hospital with a
501c thing and it's complicated what I
do but I think it's the way to do it you
just do it in your [__] backyard you
need your fence painted find a guy in
your neighborhood that paints fences and
get him to do it you know don't hire
some company from out of town you know I
think that's where it you know giving
starts is in your backyard and in your
family helping others is close around
you it doesn't get weeded out there it
does get filtered down it doesn't get
diluted you know by the time it gets to
Africa some kid you know you give a
hundred thousand dollars and some kid
gets to uh
it's a tough I've always said it's
harder to give away money yeah and feel
good about it than it is I can make
money a lot easier than I can give it
away it's it's like you know you can
give it away if you want but I mean to
have it do some good so yeah I give my
restaurant money no no with Cabo wobble
I don't give that money away but I still
do a lot of uh charity stuff are you in
food banks and stuff is Big when I tour
for 13 years and I've given a 2500
minimum to every city I've played for
the last 13 years wow man I love that
sometimes sometimes I give 10 if I make
a whole bunch you know if it's a big
city like St Louis right sell 20 000
tickets so I make a shitload I give 10.
it really it's so easy you go down to a
food bank sometimes and see how they
work and it's awesome most volunteer
they get the food almost for free a
dollar will make three meals for you
know so families you see these families
uh this I'm I'll stop going off on it
but you get me all wired up man see I
start getting Goosebumps and [__]
my heart is there it's it's just I was
poor I mean we've been poor you
understand what poor people have to deal
with and what you have to go through and
uh to to just put food on the table so
food banks the the Brilliance of that is
that when I went about 10 years ago and
there was a a family in line I was
handing out food you know helping them
with my kids I make them do it too I
make them do it yes yes you heard that
anyway I so I was given handing that
food and I see these families you know
like dress nice you know not dressed up
now but I mean you know they're clean
they weren't homeless people they
weren't and and the wife and maybe a
couple kids and they're in line and I
started talking to you know guy says hey
I'm a I'm a gardener my wife cleans
houses and you know my truck needs Tire
or something we come to the food bank
probably a couple times a month and it
helps us be able to make ends meet and I
thought now [__] yeah this is not just
you know taking people that you know
saying get a job [__] a lot of
these people have jobs and they're still
in food banks so that's what really put
the hook in me out that now that's
that's easy peasy stuff man you give
them 100 bucks and you know it's all
good so I I love it
um and and apologies but I'm so
fascinated with the Van Halen stuff oh
no go ahead no that was a peek of my
[__] life
man Hannah was one of the biggest bands
in the world I had more fun in that band
I made more money from music in that
band than anything I'd ever done in my
life and and it's it ain't the same
without Eddie and it ain't the same
without Van Halen I'd love to be in Van
Halen right now I wish we were still
together and it'd make me want to go out
and do it but you know
um when you and David Lee Roth toured
together and as I understand as I
understood the Sammy Davis tour and as I
understood it every night you would flip
a coin to see who's going to open and
who was going to close no we just did
that the first night to see who opened
the first show then after that we
flip-flopped flip-flop got it okay so
and it was the the first show was the
one in in Los Angeles no the first show
was in Cleveland Ohio and and Dave won
he got to close Okay but then in La was
that on a flip yeah and see in La it was
I my turn so Dave insisted that we do
two nights in La so we did we could sell
out anywhere it was fine you know right
but you know because he had to have well
he was trying to fight for well why I
need that town and I'm going to the same
negotiation [__] you shouldn't
be opening any I mean you shouldn't be
closing the show anyway be honest with
you at that time he didn't have a solo
career really I mean he did but he
wasn't like selling I was selling out
Arenas I was selling amphitheaters Sammy
Hagar you know with the wabos and he you
know I had a solo career so let me just
say this he has to make Jagger ask
Robert Plant you can be the biggest band
in the world and you can't necessarily
have a solo career but I had a solo
career so when I joined the big band I
went back to my solo career I'm good I
still sell a lot of tickets you know
Dave
yeah he had that little you know sort of
a big album one kind of a big album but
he didn't have a solo career you know he
was playing small places and you know he
would and so when he came in with me he
was making like 25 Grand and I I was
making 150 a night and they said oh you
guys going to make the same money Dave
gets to make 150 I said he ain't [__]
made 150 in his life instead of Van
Halen so but then I but I said I gotta
do this there's some things you just
gotta do like for me it's take care of
my health and that's why I wear a whoop
band which is the most sophisticated
Fitness tracking device known to man it
now checks your oxygen levels in your
blood your stress levels I mean it
always gives you the most insight into
your sleep your recovery how many
calories you're burning what activities
you're doing I'm telling you it really
helps keeping track of your Fitness more
than I can even say and all the coolest
people are using it man how many people
have we talked to on this podcast about
it and if you want to try it then you go
to whoop.com that's
w-h-o-o-p.com and use the promo code
Stevo and you're gonna get 10 off your
order and that's getting the new whoop
4.0 band with the waterproof charger and
you get 10 off your membership so one
more time go to whoop.com use the promo
code Stevo 10 off your order now let's
get back to it I gotta do this so I did
I've bent over backwards and he still
always tried to [__] with the with the
rules did you you're not a fun guy he's
that nice he doesn't play well with
others I'm not sure what his problem is
did you do the two nights in La yeah and
then did you so you each got to close
one night exactly okay and then you know
he he just always is about how can I you
know
make this guy look bad or not just me in
life I mean how can I make myself he's a
chest beating [__] man and you
know God bless him because like I said
that early stuff is freaking great I
yeah sure I but I I personally I've
tried to say you know he'd be a fun guy
to know but he ain't like that he ain't
like his Persona when you get around him
hit that guy man he's some other cat
when you describe what he does on
Vaudeville
like uh like with the the acrobatics and
the jumping and the dancing like
Hey listen I'm a showman too but he's
that's his gig he doesn't care about
singing if he did he'd take care of his
voice or he'd take voice lessons he'd
warm up he'd do something because the
guy sings so bad last time he was doing
shows it was embarrassing to me when
people say oh you were in Van Halen I'm
going no no no
deny it
okay they thought I was him uh so now I
see what you mean yeah but he he's a
shaman he just everything show show show
and he doesn't care about his voice
which drives me nuts man I care more
about my voice than I do my dick
wow
my dick didn't work a couple times I'd
be okay with it but you know I'd be
bummed out but if my voice [__] up on
stage I'm [__] bummed yeah
[Laughter]
when you're on the Sam and Dave tour
yeah you each have your own bands is
that how it worked yeah he had a Van
Halen tribute band he just said this is
Van Halen the guitar player did Eddie
solo the drummer did as and the bass
player even played Mikey's bass solo and
he acted like it was a Van Halen show
and it was really the wrong thing he got
ripped apart by the press for it because
you know he didn't
should have went out and presented
himself as David Lee Roth with you know
it's Van Halen's stuff and his solo said
he didn't play one [__] solo thing
you know he had some good solo songs you
know yeah
um
man you said that if you go to play a
Van Halen's song on some show that that
you're getting Alex calling up trying to
sue you saying you can't do that well on
TV he won't license the songs because we
co-wrote everything and we owned our
publishing as a team before even though
Eddie and I wrote everything Mike and
Alex work one quarter and you know our
publishing company and yes up recording
was owned by all of us equally so Ed and
Al when I left the band They I mean I
could sing anything I want in the street
and in concert but if a TV show said
we're going to film you oh you want to
be on the on the Grammys this year we
want you to sing right now or Why Can't
This be like that they said no we're not
going to license but I said that's it
[__] this [__] it's been 100 years Alex
and I tried to call him wouldn't pick up
the phone and I want to tell this story
now this is the first time this has been
heard uh I have it there's a documentary
on um the origins of rock and it's done
by the MTV people and
uh anyway and it's going to be like one
of those Netflix deals right and I'm on
the first series of it so they want to
it's about my rock and roll career
is it like yeah it's coming out probably
in June or July maybe I don't know I
don't know when it's done but I I know
my episode's done and Alex
wouldn't okay any of the Van Halen stuff
he said I don't like the way Sammy's
talking about about us and and and he
wanted it taken out the likeness and and
wouldn't let the song right now or Why
Can't This Be Love our two biggest hits
uh he wouldn't let him license it this
is my biography it's my life story and
uh they backed off but
it's just so [__] childish I mean get
out of here I wrote the song it's like
you know if I was just a singer then
that they wrote the song and hired me as
a Hired Gun I wrote the [__] songs
with Eddie so it it was really chicken
[__] but you know I wish Al Alex was
user friendly do you realize what a
great thing we could do with Michael
Anthony still sings and plays his ass
off he's in my band you know the circle
I can still sing and play my ass off
Alex can still play his ass off you know
and and and we just need a guitar player
and we can go out and play the best best
setlist would play 50 50. I've already
said it I presented it to him we'll play
50 50. we'll go to Vegas and do a
residency we'll do one big Stadium show
and give all the money away all of it
I'll take not one penny on the whole
tour let's do that to Alex I did
yeah if the hang up was the giving away
the money yeah but you're saying no well
I'd bring mine away right okay that's
what I volunteered to do I said I'll
just give mine to charity every [__]
town we go to I give it to the
Children's Hospital every [__] town
let's do these things do 10 shows do 100
shows I don't care but we got to do it
for the fans it's like those fans have
just been [__] pissed on
he won't pick up your phone call no man
I I love that so much that you would
want to give away all of your money to
do I don't want to give it all away but
I would to do it I don't need the money
but I would I would do it and and what
the other thing I really love is that
when you talk about doing a a Eddie
tribute
that you would have Eddie's son Wolfgang
do that if it was like a one-time deal a
couple shows and that's it but there's
just this respect that you have for for
wolf that you wouldn't want uh to bog
him down with an ongoing gig where he
mimics oh no honest to God I wouldn't
recommend that if I was his father I
would say no you're doing great he's
doing great I mean this guy really stuck
to his guns yeah and blew he blows my
mind I had no idea he could sing like
that I've been around a kid for half his
life you know and and I never knew he's
saying I knew he was always playing
guitar and playing bass and playing
drums he's a great little musician but
the truth in the matter is he he really
found his Niche he's going for it he's
out working his ass off and I I wouldn't
I wouldn't distract him from that to be
his father it'd be like his his father's
Shadow that's terrible I feel like the
devil yeah ruined his kid's life here no
so he's doing the right thing but we
could do a couple one-offs yeah how do
you describe it do it big for the big
time one time one time for the big time
I guess
I didn't invent that [__]
one time for the big time two times for
the big time maybe four times for the
victim the problem is is when if we did
that one show no matter how big this
place no matter what the ticket price it
would go bam and the business world
would come [__] down our throats and
our managers should be going come on
guys you know this is the big payday for
us you know and it's like I'm it would
not it's not a problem but you know it
would be so tempting to go out and work
it and milk it and work it milk it I
don't think Wolfie would do and like I
said I wouldn't even recommend he'd do
it there's so many great guitar players
right there you know right if you were
to go on tour again would you do buses
or private jets oh I got my own chat
I've been flying private
I can't sit in one of these busted man I
get seasick and he's like yeah
that was the greatest he's like I'm
sorry what
how dare no it's like uh and apologies
again but back to me Van Halen
you got David Lee Roth he's in Van Halen
from 78 to 85. then you come in and from
85 to 96. then you leave how long before
David Lee Roth comes back it was a long
time they're so dysfunctional it's like
um
Van Halen Dave was a leader when I
joined the band I became the leader it
was just gifted to me you know and it
was like well I'd say well what time you
guys want to rehearse tomorrow you know
or whatever and be like well I don't
know what time you under here since two
o'clock okay you know it's like then
pretty soon it's like don't bother
asking hey guys see you tomorrow too you
know right it's it just became kind of
like that and so when when I left the
band they just didn't have a leader and
and Eddie and Alex kind of they lead in
their own way but Eddie just leads
musically he just goes in the studio you
walk in he's in there playing he goes
what do you think of this and and it
just go it happens and Alex is right
there with him you know so um it's kind
of like
that's why they couldn't they couldn't
made a function our manager died he was
our fearless of my managers the guy that
came in our fearless leader and I was
the the band guy and without that they
just couldn't put anything together look
how long it took him to get an album out
with Gary Sharon then that didn't work
so they threw that out the window and
tried to get Dave back again they tried
to get Dave back five times I think it
it's like dysfunctional it's like no one
can agree on [__] I want it black okay
[__] it Paint It Black did well no I
think I want it white now okay paint it
white no no wait a minute here you know
like [__] it's like being in the Middle
East trying to haggle over a piece of
fruit or something you know what I mean
right I don't know if you've ever done
that but they want to haggle how much is
that 100 okay no no we'll give you a
better deal than that oh really oh how
much
90. okay 90. yeah remember in Morocco it
was just anything we wanted it was like
how much you pay yeah exactly I don't
know if they want to handle they just
you know don't there's no such thing as
just saying here's the way it goes let's
just do it I hate that [__]
it's like such a waste of time as
they've been stuck in a [__] mud man
yeah I'm just I'm a I like to move fast
what was the album you did with Mickey
Hart was that oh marching to Mars that
was my first solo album how was that
with Mickey Hart did you know him from
Monterey or or back in the day or you
just met him the dead because we're a
barrier guy yeah and Bob Weirs lived
down the street for me for 100 years wow
and uh uh when I my home up there still
still Bob still is there and uh Jerry
bought a house next to me now you know
whenever somebody mentions The Grateful
Dead I get excited I just was always
such a fan of Jerry Garcia and the
Grateful Dead and you know what else I'm
a fan of is getting excited and when
it's time to get excited
sometimes I like to have Bluetooth
tablets why because they've got the same
active ingredient as both Viagra and
Cialis but they only cost a fraction of
the price and they are delicious
when I want to get down with Lux it's
time for Bluetooth and it's time for you
to get an entire month's Supply
completely for free all you got to pay
is five bucks for shipping now how do
you get this deal you go to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
Stevo that's bluechew.com and use the
promo code Stevo it's the deal of the
century so jump on it and let's get back
to it
and so we we're all kind of friends and
Mickey and I you know Mickey and I
hooked up in a weirdest [__] way my
wife was pregnant I bought a house in
Maui I just got
as Van Halen was going through the worst
time right before I got thrown out and I
said I'm buying a house in Maui I'm
taking my some time off [__]
going to Stew to do whatever you want
but I'm gonna have my wife's baby over
here in Maui we're gonna have uh I'm
gonna deliver the [__] baby right wow
I was really into that and so you were
gonna deliver who's going to deliver it
but with you know some help they have a
Lamaze system where you're doing water
and it's you know all natural yeah
childbirth so we were all into that for
our first baby came and her birthday was
yesterday by the way so we're talking
about Cayman now she's your fan by the
way yeah yeah and so Kama uh was like
happen to be breached but we didn't know
it at the time so we're flying over
there we're on an airplane we got a dog
that we tranquilized and stuck him in a
[__] bag a little dog called Winchell
and we're sneaking him in there and Bill
Cosby is on that flight and and Mickey
hearts on Netflix did Bill give your dog
the pill [__] bill the dog got out
got out of the thing right when we were
landed it [__] woke up Zip Zip Zip
Zip you don't [__] scratch it was a
little dog and uh the [__] Bill Cosby
goes oh look at the cute little doggy I
go oh [__] I look at my dogs walking
down the aisle of the airplane right so
they said oh you can't get off the plane
you're gonna you know quarantine your
dog well yeah the dog's gotta go blah
blah we're going what the [__] we're
gonna do my wife's praying she's crying
Mickey Hart's on the plane his wife is a
lawyer and she goes hold on here let me
work on this for you and so Mickey was
going on vacation we were moving in
their house and we spent the whole month
over there together and we started
writing songs and doing all kinds of
stuff way back then and he became such a
dear friend but it was what we did is we
put the dog back in it in a container
someone who got off the plane went and
bought a container there was a fan on
the plane a lady that said I'll go do
this and she went and got a container we
had sat on the plane for like three
[__] hours put the dog on the
container ship the dog back kari's
friend picked the dog up so we we moved
to Maui without the dog yeah Hawaii
doesn't [__] around about bringing dogs
oh I know
at covid too yeah but this was back in
this was like 27 years ago yeah yeah did
you have a favorite decade to tour in I
would have to imagine it's the 80s oh
yeah 70s and 80s 70s and 80s Montrose we
didn't make the money but that was the
year the era
of I mean just think about the 70s
that's when glitter Rock I mean you'd
[__] dress like [__] women big old
[__] high-heeled shoes and nylon
stockings and [__] you know on stage
makeup [__] girls going crazy like we
walk out the back door there's like 20
groupies it's like hey
come on here's you know go to the
holiday and here we are they'd be
waiting there for you it was anything
goes man and it was just sex drugs in
rock and roll To The Bone and it was
exciting time for rock and roll because
for me I mean I'm starting to make it
and um well yeah I mean there's very
artistic Freedom during that time and
80s too but 70s were really cool some
people some people would argue that
Montrose made the first heavy metal
album not the first but we were early
yeah we influenced Van Halen and crew
and you know and all those bands that
came after L.A the heavy Rock scene that
happened that was pretty much Montrose
was the king of that you know we
invented it who would you give credit to
for the first metal album it's got to be
Sabbath huh
Deep Purple probably purple I don't know
you know metal wasn't metal back then
like now it was just it just was hard
rock you know it was crazy now you know
like but um
I don't know I was really I was really
into uh I was really into the who I was
really into uh
Zeppelin of course you just put out I
don't know who did the first one I don't
know she said I wasn't as much in the
Sabbath I was in a Sabbath but not as
much as I was in into Led Zeppelin and
right and the who in a band called free
sure free I love free I did too I was
gonna ask him that was Montrose [__] see
because I heard you talking about how
you um
we're just we're pretty dead against
like the the whole FM thing and the
problem with capital was that they just
wanted you to write hits so that they
wouldn't have to do any work to promote
the band The Radio would do the job for
you and you were like no I want to be
more edgy I want to be kind of more hard
rock I want to be like a tough guy like
rock and roll I don't want to be a pop
star I don't want to do the radio no no
I was I was embarrassed about you they
would hand me songs to you know that
said why don't you record this song and
I'll go I would have [__] record that
song and you know I was I was a punk you
know kind of punkish a little bit you
know I had an attitude anyway and uh and
you know that doesn't work with
corporate guys I know that now I could
have been a lot I could have had a hit
earlier if I did you know kiss a little
ass right and then that was that that
was what you said too is that uh you
know you wanted to be edgy and tough and
and you know a real like badass rock
star not a pop star but but you don't
mind if uh you know if if tune like
breaks through onto the radio and that's
how you describe the Rolling Stones yeah
that's free was my favorite band because
of all right now it was such a that was
that that was there one that just said
exactly every now and then somebody
would have one that snuck through and I
said I want one of those yeah that's
what I wanted I did not want you know
the typical Carpenter's hit you know
yeah
Taj Mahal once said uh he said don't
ever record a song you don't want to
sing for the rest of your life and I
thought that's [__] brilliant like
you never know if it's gonna blow up or
not you just get a hit and you're saying
oh Margaritaville yeah well Jimmy don't
care I shot that I'm sure that's a place
on the sick
there you go there's a career song it
snuck through you know every now and
then I wanted and you know when you're
trying to write that way
it's you know your chances you're
rolling the dice are not as good as you
know as uh man how about the bassist
from free
Andy Frazier that [__] Mr Big that
terrible the way he played and he wrote
those songs you know Paul told me that
Paul actually
was trying to be him when he sang and
Annie Frazier had a solo record and it
was bass and drums and and an electric
piano and sometimes right
and he's saying and it was Soulful blue
[__] it was bad ass uh he's saying more
like Paul Rodgers he was cool really
cool singer he sounded like he was in
love like you know I used to always say
this [__] could sing about
anything it sounds like he really means
it you know what I mean I like that you
know some people just have that thing
like Michael McDonald had he opens his
mouth and it sounds like he's Soulful
passion like pouring his heart out to
you man [__] I have to scream my ass off
and hold my nuts and all that to get to
sound convincing then then Bad Company
came along after free and they were like
more mainstream yeah bad company was
really a big influence on me too
Montrose we uh we were on the same bill
with bad companies debut and and London
at uh it's the stadium uh not Wembley
Stadium there's another Stadium I forget
what it was 90 000 people The Who Humble
Pie Lou Reed
Montrose
Bad Company Maggie Bell wow you guys
were they make their debut so they had
you guys were above
Bad Company yeah but Peter Grant their
manager Led Zeppelin's manager held them
in traffic and they made us go on as
soon as we went on that [__]
team walking through the back door
it's true it's true story I'm going [__]
how do we get [__] on this you know
you know my my heroes I wanted to you
know wow I got thousand people yeah it
was a big Charlton Festival Charlton a
big soccer stadium was that the biggest
you've ever done God no yeah right up
there no I'm just about you know 90 180
I mean you can't get much bigger than
that I've never been to South America I
keep getting offers to go to South
America but it's like I want to go but
it's never the right time it's like I'm
gonna say oh [__] we do I'm just not
going to tour that month we just got
offered again
for like I forget what it was I had to
turn it down again but you know they
play for 300 000 I don't see any reason
to play for 300 000 [__] people I'm
gonna tell you something right now you
walk out on stage your [__] legs go
weak you know you just go the energy
just sucks it out of you 100 000 people
sucks the energy what did Tommy tell you
last night was uh their capacity in
South America just recent well we didn't
talk about it but I know they just got
back yeah man what was it I mean like I
turned 300 000 probably yeah they have a
huge soccer team because it's the sports
so big and a [__] Rock Fans I mean
I've seen pictures of it I talked to
Metallica and all these my buddies that
go down there and play all the time and
I'm going man I don't even [__] want
to walk out to that many people I did
feel like a the [__] piss ant Theory
you know what I mean like yeah I mean
what's the difference is there a stark
difference between going out and
performing with sixty thousand ninety
thousand or is it all the same after a
certain it's all the same after about
20. it really is 20 you start getting up
in the 50s and 60s I mean I don't
dislike it but it's [__] it's you
know it [__] you up man you come off
that stage as a shot man you know it's
like at my age I'm worried I'll go back
out [__] drop dead you know yeah I
feel like I feel like you'd be like
desensitized after that like being that
high yeah and like experiencing that
level of energy that yeah night after
night too yeah going and eating a pizza
at the cafe just really doesn't do it
you know or yeah you know Van Halen when
we did the Monsters of Rock Tour we only
did one stadium tour in my rain we do
four nights in every city in the planet
you know for Arenas you know 18 19 000
people each night but uh that was our
our go-to or we had a really good
manager before he died I left her and he
was really smart financially he'd say
you're going to play for 56 000 people
and you're not going to make as much
money as you're going to make for those
20 000 people in that Arena because the
production they got to have bigger it
takes three days to set up you're gonna
lose two or three days where you can't
play because your production is being
set up and and so when we did it we had
56 trucks on the road we had three
stages three Arena three sets of Lights
three sets of sound on the Monsters of
Rock Tour we we didn't make as much
money and you know and with Metallica
was the opening act back then you know
it's really great wow and that's you
know became good for I got him on it on
the bill but we became really good
friends but on that tour but point is I
got hurt on the first show I fell down
broke my tailbone so every night I
couldn't stand up I couldn't wipe my ass
man so I had to have doctors every day
giving me shots of cortisone right into
my tailbone of my spine I couldn't then
I'd going back and forth to my doctor to
an LA uh and where I lived in Malibu and
Eddie and I lived with neighbors here I
had a great doctor and he was he was
helping me get through it but I was
getting on flights after shows flying
home privately getting back you know
Landing jump put on running on stage my
I got ear infection I got a sinus I
didn't sing good once except the first
night in the whole [__] tour I
was beat and dead so I never really got
the experience that the energy of the
stadium property
and you know whenever I did a festival
by you know with my own bands and stuff
like that I just don't like those
hundred thousand eighty thousand
festivals it's yeah I just don't feel
like I'm connected
I'd rather play the Cabo Wabo you know
at my own place and and it's like it
it's so special to walk out and feel
like you really are in a in a connecting
in an event
um I think Van Halen today you know
would be awesome on these big stadium
shows and all that if we were still
around today we're more mature I
wouldn't go out and try to work so
[__] hard I used to go and try to you
know stage I mean like 170 feet across
man I [__] spit to the other side
[Music]
so because I was a nut you know I had no
control on stage I get out there I'm a
nervous performance so when the bell
rings for me I just go nuts you know not
anymore but I mean it's way that was my
style I was so nervous I couldn't stand
in one place you get so nervous you
black out ever no but I never passed
down on stage anyway
how did you break your tailbone
how'd you break your tailbone you felt
like off the stage well we had a brand
new production because we had three
Productions and so everything got
delayed and so we were playing the first
night was three nights in a place called
uh the place where Stevie Ray Vaughan
died on a helicopter um Alpine Valley
Alpine Valley we did three nights there
to open anything the first night hey
thank you we had steel stairs that went
up to this Riser you know been the old
days where you had a big Riser behind a
drum Riser and everybody go up there and
see a couple songs
um and I didn't I didn't know the stage
we didn't get to rehearse on it and I
was walking backwards and the [__]
first song Summer Nights opened a song
with summer nights in my radio and I
just [__] hit the chorus and stepped
back and went right on a steel Corner
hit my tailbone and the most [__] up
thing maybe you guys should think this
is funny you you probably used to
getting hurt I'm not used to it so
I [__] going oh [__] I was numb it
went everything went numb in my body in
my mid body and I was going what the
[__] what the [__] you know and I
reached back and it was like a
grapefruit big ass grapefruit on my ass
and my tail and I pulled my hand out and
was full of blood and I almost fainted
because I went over to my crew guy and I
and I go
the [__] going on man and he looks at
you like oh man
and I couldn't see it I had to go back
out and finish the show and
that whole tour was [__] up because of
them okay that was our only stadium tour
in those days there weren't a lot of
Stadium tours I bet I bet
um the uh the Dynamics of making more
money from four Arena shows than one
Stadium show oh twice as much money
before as much money so that's because
even though you gotta do the show four
times you're only setting up the show
Once yeah that's part of it but I mean
I'm talking about making twice as much
so let's say if it was two two Arenas uh
to a one Stadium it's about the same
amount of people that one Stadium show
the the cost of the stadium the whole
setup of the size of the stage you got
to build it from scratch there's no you
know Arenas have they're more user
friendly you know right right so your
stuff is mostly customized for that if
that's what you're doing and you go out
and you do a stadium you got to start
over man you got to build a whole brand
new production you know that stuff costs
half a million bucks easily so you can
spend if you're going to do one Stadium
show it's going to cost you 250 300 000
you know and you do an arena show it's
going to cost you 100 Grand so you know
right do the math and also you can't
sell those tickets way in the back of
that Stadium for the same price as a
thing I mean I'm assuming that's part of
it too right but it was real expensive
to do steam it we just our ego we just
wanted to do it I said no we don't care
we're rich you know we'll make plenty of
money don't get me wrong like we weren't
losing money but it was like more
profitable to do Arenas and now it's
more profitable to do amphitheaters than
anything yeah what is that like four to
six thousand no the seating thousand
yeah they're anywhere from 15 to
somewhere somewhere 20. at the Irvine
Amphitheater yeah Irvine's a small it's
like about eight I just played that
place uh last year you did the Sam and
Dave show at the universal Amphitheater
that was small see the reason we did
that because Dave because it was my turn
to thank Dave's insisted upon doing two
two nights so they put us in a smaller
place normally we would have played a
bigger
yeah you know Dave was he was a piece of
work
really something huh
um when uh if he was sitting here right
now we'd be going
the dude would be tripping he'd be like
oh is that right Sam and that's it
he'd call me Sam I don't mind being
called Sam it's just his attitude right
look at you and [__] he'll talk to other
people about you yeah
he's a trip man I actually like the guy
he entertains the [__] out of me okay I
mean I think he's an entertaining guy I
I think have you had him on your show no
oh well
I'd be open to it and um I think I would
tell him that uh while his flamboyance
his his uh on stage Antics and
acrobatics and everything is just so
fantastic that between David Lee Roth
and Sammy Hagar I gotta believe Sammy
Hagar is a happier person he'd get up
and walk
he's not coming on now
I believe you know and then like you
know I don't even think that's a dig you
you know I think uh oh no he's not he's
not uh user friendly that's whether he's
happier and I have no idea
you say that um that you had 10 good
years with Van Halen and one bad year
yeah well two bad years now because the
reunion was bad so I had nine good years
one and two bad years because it was 11
it was ten years all together at the end
one year reunion which was just hell but
um I'm glad we did it but at the same
time it was just that was the 80 dates
the 80s I tried to quit after 40.
actually I can't do this anyway yeah but
you were gonna get sued if you did that
yeah so we we had we split airplane we
were on one big plane and we we ended up
on two smaller planes oh wow and what
year was that was that uh 2014. so so
2004 and what made what made it such a
disaster was it that the substance abuse
had progressed yeah substance abuse had
progressed to a really bad level and
once again I really hate to say anything
bad about Mr Eddie Van Halen the
greatest of the [__] greatest after
he's gone and but it was during that
time was not a good time for him and he
it's the worst he played in his whole
life that I ever know of you know and it
was not good for him I don't think that
that's a disparaging comment because I
mean it was 2007 when he acknowledged
himself that he had to get in there and
do something about it yeah
and it was it was about time because he
was going to die I heard some stories
yeah like yourself I'm I'm glad you're
still standing against a lot of love for
that I'm serious if you don't want to
live [__] it but if you want to live you
gotta do the right thing if you want to
live right Mikey and I shared a dress
room and we would wait we'd sit in our
dress room and when it was time to go
and we our tour manager be there with us
our security guys that we'd just be
sitting there like us okay it's time to
go on it's like you would wait until you
heard Eddie's guitar go
yeah okay that's the first thing he did
backstage hit plug in backstage and he
would see if it was going to squee I'll
make the you know the big big badass Ed
tone and until we heard that we didn't
bother going out near the back of the
stage because every night it'd be like
that serious like hey I don't we don't
know if the guy's gonna make it I mean
it was like man crazy that's horrible it
it breaks my heart it really and it
broke my heart then too but I got pissed
pretty soon I started saying [__] this
[__] you know I'm here to you know do a
job and it's making it difficult so so
yeah that was bad we we really hit a
bumping Road as friends on that tour
do you have any fun uh Bob Weir Jerry
Garcia party stories
well
not Jerry Jerry Jerry was a cool guy but
I never was around him that much he died
when they moved into the house next door
to me that's when he 94. yeah he died in
95. he checked himself in yeah Van Halen
had the balance record out and I
remember we did uh we were in New York
when I heard it and I was I went until
we were on David Letterman's show and I
heard that Jerry Garcia pass oh wow and
uh they found him with a smile on his
face dead in the bed in his rehab yeah
he went to rehab trying to get cleaned
up and he was he was so bad he didn't
make it but he used or he just had a
heart attack I'm not sure but he was
using at that time heavy I think it was
I think it was heroin I probably
shouldn't say that because I don't know
I think it's commonly known that it was
heroin yeah and he just he didn't make
it through the rehab he was trying to
clean up and he just moved into the
house next door to me and him his wife
Deborah she still lives there oh wow and
uh I thought oh this is the greatest fan
I got you know because Jerry and I we
only played together once at Sweetwater
in downtown but Bob and I we Bob and I
used to run together all the time you
know he's so uh conscientious yoga and
everything he's the greatest guy in the
world man he's he's been a runner we
used to run him down up the mountain and
I'd bring him over my house a little
Studio there and we'd listen to my new
songs and be going oh you know Bob's a
real funny guy he's
he's
the most
he's the sweetest human being on the
planet I can't say it he don't have an
evil bone in his body he's not capable
of being evil he's just such a nice guy
he's there for you Bob I'm doing a
charity event can you help her brother
well let me check yeah I can be there
don't you don't have to call him again
except right before it because he
forgets [__] but other than that other
than that he will [__] be there and
he's just he's just really a good guy I
wrote a letter arguably the most uh
impassioned letter to Bob Weir in
proposing the idea of him coming on this
WOW [__] great has he done it I I
think that we got a response uh I forget
him from his daughters or publicist but
not now maybe later well he's always
working you're gonna have to go to him
but that's what the what you're doing is
awesome exactly thank you
we bring it I'll make this happen I
would definitely I walk in the room I'm
[__] send him a text say Bob you got
to do this show I uh I I I I followed
the Grateful Dead there was the now the
jackass director makes fun of me for
being such a deadhead when my first my
first dead show was 1990 and it had uh
you know it was like 1994 I went to
every single show on the uh East Coast
summer tour night
um so yeah uh if the last show was in
Soldier Field in 95 I was there enough
so that was back then uh they were still
they were the dead they were the
Grateful Dead
oh yeah yeah yeah Jerry died in 95. that
was the [__] that banned man they were
they were like a wave of their you know
I used to go to their shows too and it
was just it was like an amoeba thing it
just kind of swell up and then it would
get all high and then it would just kind
of fall apart and nobody would care and
everybody got to go about their business
music keep going they would swell up
again it was so [__] unique what
those guys did did you see that Series
on Amazon that they won a long exchange
trip no the train trip yeah yeah yeah
dude it was the greatest series man and
uh I love that you know him and and
um Bob I consider a dear friend I'll go
there for it Mickey's a dear friend too
but Mickey and I don't stay in touch
like Bob and I Bob comes to Cabo Bob
comes to my shows every time I did a
residency last year and the year before
I did 14
shows in Vegas and uh he came to three
of them and he drove his bus he was in
Denver did a show and I've said hey Bob
you should come down to this room's
really cool and he goes oh okay and uh
yeah I'll be there I said okay what you
know I'll send he shows up Parks his bus
in the parking lot right and I'm going
what are you gonna stay in your bed I
said yeah yeah I got a gig tomorrow
night
he drove in on a day off he comes on
stage you know plays he's doing it in
the bus he's not flying around huh
some guys like the bus thing I I don't I
try to hurry I get motion sickness me
too I do if I sleep on a bus I'd wake up
we will drive this son of a [__] to the
Bay Area for Bob Weir on a dime well his
daughter goes to school down here so uh
he he'll you know he comes down once in
a while I'll make this happen I'm tired
but yeah it'd be a nice drive anyway
going up there yeah oh man going up the
coast Big Sur yeah coasting this thing
I had to close my eyes all the time
because I'm just getting nauseous man I
I hate to try to use you for for
bookings but man we gotta get Guy Fieri
too oh no no yeah same thing guys busier
than anybody yeah that [__] is
crazy yeah he's in Vegas right oh he's
got [__] three or four TV shows he's
got 77 restaurants and he goes and opens
them and works them and he's got you
know he's my partner with Santo tequila
so he's got a brand he's got a tequila
brand and he goes around and does
in-stores which I won't do my fans are
too [__] crazy you know it's like if
you say I'm going to be in an in-store
they'll be like they say well you don't
have to sign 100 bottles oh yeah you're
right a thousand people show up and if I
sign 100 bottles I try to get out of
there I get called every [__] name I
mean they calling me Roth and [__] you
know
man my fans do not go for it you've got
to stay right there all [__] day
until the last ones and everyone's got a
story so it ain't like just signing go
right my fans are too intense but he
does it he goes and he does you know
BevMo he does you know Safeway in-store
Costco in store wow and and he sits
there and signs autographs takes people
that [__] is the hardest working
guy I've ever met in my life and when he
takes a vacation he goes out into the
Wilderness and camps and hunts and does
crazy [__] wow right he like he he's
like getting up at four o'clock in the
morning and doing East Coast TV that
makes me think we got to get Ferris
grills too Bear Grylls yeah I'll try to
get guy to do it but just get nailing
him down it's gonna be harder than Bob
Bob's yeah Bob's slippery but but guys
busy
that's great dude you're the greatest
Sammy I'm just one of them
yeah I uh I mean I've enjoyed talking to
you man
um what can we uh encourage people to
pay attention to for you wow that's a
beautiful thought I I don't know I don't
like hyping my stuff I wear my my own
shirts but see I own my Brands you know
I don't endorse if I endorse something I
wouldn't wear it you know so all right
what about the Netflix thing you said
you had an episode I don't know when
it's coming on is all I can say is wait
if you go if you're traveling and you go
through an airport and they have a
Sammy's Beach Bar and Grill or a cobble
wobble because I'm about to build one in
Carolina or if you have if you see
something that I uh you know endorse or
own in a in a restaurant support it
because I take the money and we help
other people you mean uh something that
you endorse or on in an airport yes in
an airport because that's where I give
all the money away to that Community
that's great yeah yeah so if you're
going to Maui hey and the food's good
too you know yeah and drinks are good
you know but we'll send you a photo of
us eating there if we ever show
this what you're wearing is the uh
what's it called uh ready to drink RTD
yeah ready to drink mixer sparkling rum
cocktails and they're [__] good
everything I make I do it because I want
to be better than the competition like
when I told you when I was a rock star
you know yeah I don't consider myself a
rock I couldn't consider myself a former
rock star but I can still sing and play
and I like to do it but anyway uh I just
wanted to be the biggest and the Badness
I was seeing faster you know play faster
and jump higher and you know talk faster
uh that's the way I feel about when I
make a product I I wanna only reason why
I do it is to try I said I can do better
than that you know it's like people say
why don't you make you know fine wine
because I'm a fine wine I drink Romani
kantis and Shiva blancs and Vegas
cecilias uh and that's kind of wine I
drink why don't you make wine so it's
like I [__] can't make wine better
than that you know but I can make rtd's
better than that [__] these rules of
drinking so I started I did it and
that's so that's all I can tell you my
products stand behind 100 I own it I
don't take other people's money I take
on Partners if they're the right person
like Guy Fieri wanted to be part of this
tequila so I brought him on but it ain't
like I'm I'm not a businessman I'm sorry
I'm not I got good business since I've
made more mistakes though than most
people would imagine I just had a couple
winners no that's all I want to say
that's I'd want to get that off my chest
that if you see something with my name
on it I stand behind 100 it's better
than the competition and if it's in an
airport feel good about it because it's
going to help people yeah all right Dan
thank you take care of if you stay alive
I like you yeah I like you too tell you
a real quick story
Kelsey Chelsea's uh that show remember
the TV show uh Chelsea yeah Chelsea yeah
yeah Chelsea Chelsea she had her end of
show party when she canceled her thing
and I and I was invited so with some
other people so I went and uh they had
all and I brought my booze and nervous
when I first had my beach bar room and
uh your buddy Johnny Knoxville was there
and and and he kept and I kept calling
him Stevo on it we had a [__] bus
going everybody had my buzz on him and
uh and I kept calling you Steve and my
daughter Kayla was with me and she says
a long time ago but uh she was she was
still hip to you guys I was hip to you
guys too don't get me wrong but I mean
she was like a fan she's going she kept
saying dad
I mean like what that's [__] Stevo
man and he didn't say [__] we took
pictures and I'd stand next to him he's
a great guy yeah anyway I had to tell
you
we should have started with that
it's hold open yeah thank you so much I
gotta get I gotta get my wife's uh
camera I gotta take a picture yeah I
want to take it with the front of this
[__] up van come on now let's see okay
was that something or what Man Sammy
Hagar
and God that feels like such a long time
ago like time goes really slow in
Australia man this uh this tour is epic
but it's challenging man I might be a
little bit worn out I might be a little
bit burned out but
dared thank you for sticking around to
the end